[موسيقى]
نداءات عند وجهتها منظمه الصحه العالميه
من مخاطر مقاومه المضادات الحيويه على
الصحه بسبب التعاطي العشوائيه اليوم اصبحت
هذه التحذيرات في محلها بعد نجحت
البكتيريا مرض السرطان واصبحت في المركز
الثاني اكبر قاتل بعد القلب في العالم
الاف الباحثين اجتمعوا في دراسه تابعه
لمؤسسه الطبيه وخلصوا لانه يمكن ان تعزى
وفاه واحده من اصل كل ثماني حالات وفاه
عالميا الى الامراض الناجمه على الاصابه
بالبكتيريا يشيروا دراسه ايضا لانه من بين
30 نوعا من البكتيريا المدروسه تعتبر خمسه
منها مسؤوله عن اكثر من نصف الوفيات في
العالم
[موسيقى]
حاله من كل من حالات وفاه هي بسبب
البكتيريا في العالم هي ثاني مسبب الوفاه
بعد نوبات القلب كيف يمكن تفسير ذلك
الطبيه هذا بكل بساطه لسه على ارقام هذه
ممكن تكون اسوى في المستقبل للاسف الشديد
بكل بساطه انا دحين لو سالتكم قديش يعيش
عندنا في جسمنا
اثنين ملعب تنس تخيلي هذه فيها اكثر من
اثنين
كيلو جرام
كلها
من يوم ما احنا ناخذ لها مضادات هي حقتنا
كويس
تقوم الا الله سبحانه وتعالى يدي لها
جينات عشان تسوي لنا مقاومه
اوكي تقوم بعد كده لا سمح الله جاء التهاب
في البول ما عادني الاقي مضاد نستخدمه
يعني بس دكتور خلينا نفهم احنا صرنا كانه
اخر فتره على يمين وشمال عم ناخذ انت
بيوتك هل صار هذا هو السبب انه بدل ما
تكون تقاوم هذه البكتيريا صارت تؤدي الى
بكتيريا ضاره في المستقبل هذا هو التفسير
العلمي الحقيقي احنا سرنا نعطي مضاد يمين
يسار كل واحد سخن يوم اخذ مضاد مضبوط
وللاسف الشديد احيانا المريض يطالب به
واحيانا الطبيب يعطي بدون داعي
للاسف الشديد احنا يقولوا عندك عمره كده
رحت احد قال لك عندي انفلونزا
وحديكي موبايل كيف
هو فيروس كيف هتديني بعد
علشان احميك من لا يجيك بكتيريا هذا مخالف
للعلم ما ينفع هذا الكلام